people who try to write code which seems
clever or which seems like it's doing
some mysterious stuff is often a sign of
a bad code and a bad programmer sequel
databases would perform much better than
nosql in this video i'm gonna share my
five learnings as a software developer
which i have learned over the last six
seven eight years of working with code
with so many programming languages so
many frameworks and so many technologies
also if you are new to the channel make
sure you subscribe and like the video to
receive daily updates on programming
content released on goldam this video is
a part of code dam's t-shirt giveaway
program for the month if you want to
take part and win an amazing goal damn
t-shirt all you have to do is leave a
comment on this video about what you
think and that's it you are eligible if
your comment gets a heart from code damn
you will win a t-shirt for absolutely
free my first learning as a developer is
that typed languages are always better
than dynamic languages now even if you
take example of javascript versus
typescript i heavily believe after
working for so many years with
javascript and years with typescript as
well that thai script is a superior
alternative sure it has that learning
curve where you have to write types and
do a lot of checks but if you're working
on a medium to life large size project
especially with teams it will be very
very useful to have a type system in
place similarly for other languages like
golang or even c plus plus as a matter
of fact the more types you have the more
restrict you can have in terms of how
well your program can be maintained
compared to dynamic typing type
languages i used to enjoy and work with
javascript and python and things like
these a lot but that mindset has changed
over the time because of the discipline
you get with the typed languages my
second learning as a developer is don't
try to solve a solved problem for
example in the last some of one of the
last videos we took a look at how you
can create a aws like pipeline which
would be linked as a card somewhere here
that is fine in order to learn how to do
that but it's almost always a better
idea to go ahead and use a solution like
max dot n or cloudflare stream if you're
building a pipeline if you are running
it on a small scale where you can afford
the cost or you know you don't have a
lot of traffic or specific use case
coming in for example if you take a look
at that video you're gonna see that that
involves a lot of components to make it
scalable and robust and you know making
sure nothing goes down and so on and so
forth and it's usually not a good deal
compared to what you would get if you
just use a built solution for that right
similar thing exists for open source
software a lot of time we as a developer
get stuck on the fact that hey i'm not
able to code that solution i want to
code my own solution whereas there might
be a simpler solution existing out there
as an open source package so don't try
to reinvent the wheel as developers
especially when you're working on a
startup or a business or a small scale
project which you want to hit under a
deadline it is important to stand on the
shoulders of the giant right for
learning part i do believe that it is
good if you just go out and experiment
building your own stuff but for the most
part i do believe i mean software mostly
has been built in this following way
right nobody really builds everything
from scratch otherwise you would
probably have to start from hardware
again so yeah i mean you should just try
to go ahead and focus on what your
software does uniquely compared to
building a lot of non-essential parts
which are already built for you my third
learning is that people who try to write
code which seems clever or which seems
like it's doing some mysterious stuff is
often a sign of a bad code and a bad
programmer why do i say that i say that
because a lot of time i would say like
almost all the times you never want a
code which appears mysterious but
actually a piece of code which can be
read by another human because chances
are that would happen eventually right
if your product gets famous or you know
you want to work on some refactoring
part or anything clever code is not
going to help you those ternary
operators and those fumble syntax and
you know shortcuts which you're taking
in the code that might be you know good
for the computer or the computer might
not even care but people who are
maintaining your code will most likely
just just have a bad time maintaining
that code so as a developer that is one
of the reasons i don't even like
competitive coding because that teaches
you a lot of such practices where you
have to i mean not exactly teaches you
but it's more like a convention in a
competitive coding space so that mindset
takes time to change right so you don't
want to be writing that sort of syntax
where everything is jumbled you're
writing one letter variable names you're
assigning them you're using shortcuts to
write code real world code is massively
different and needs to be massively
different in order to be maintained and
scaled properly by a lot of people
together my fourth important learning
which i have seen is that if you're
building real world applications in a
lot of cases if they are even moderately
complex you're gonna see that there is a
lot of relation between the data right
and relational data is best suited for
rdbms like mysql or postgres or
basically these sql databases mongodb
although we had damn also use mongodb
but i have realized that usually in
general
sql databases would perform much better
than nosql for managing and maintaining
this data for a number of reasons one of
them being that relational data which is
the real world data is easily mapped
into databases like mysql or postgres
mongodb on the other hand follows the
nosql ones follow they do have the
ability to have relations but it's it's
it seems like
fake right because eventually you would
have to perform a second query or you
would have to do an aggregation to
perform a lookup anyway so and plus
these
databases work and operate best if the
data is not relational that means nosql
would work best if the data is not
relational so
yeah i mean either if you're able to
structure your data in the following way
then that's great but i have seen that a
lot of data in fact is a relational so
you would have connections between
different collections and different
documents and so on and so forth and for
those i would say like you know using an
rdbms makes much more sense compared to
a nosql database and my fifth point
which kind of like overrules all the
other four which i mentioned is that
there is usually no one right way to do
a certain thing take an example of oop
object-oriented programming which is a
very widely taught topic in universities
schools and so on now oop is fine as a
programming paradigm but to be honest
it's not as popular as you would you
know think it is especially if you're
working with things like javascript and
typescript and stuff like this on the
back end sure it has a concept of
classes javascript even languages like
javascript has a concept of classes and
so on but at least we what i have seen
in code dam and the way we have
structured it and what i have seen in
other code bases i mean javascript is
not even an object-oriented language
it's a prototypal based inheritance
language so there is no one right and
wrong way to do things as long as you
are able to follow some of the best
practices again this could be another
point that all best practices are not
best practices and if you're following
them all you're doing something wrong
follow some of the best practices of the
ecosystem but understand that it
varies a lot from ecosystem to ecosystem
in the place in the tech stack which
you're choosing the technologies which
you're building for so these were my top
five general understandings which i
could think of from the last few years
what do you think about them do you have
something you want to share as an
experience with others let me know in
the comments below make sure you like
the video subscribe to the channel and
hit the bell icon in order to keep
receiving the updates that is all for
this one i'm gonna see you in the next
video really soon
[Music]
[Music]
you